die spektakuläre entdeckung wurde
möglich durch das nasa-weltraumteleskop
tests identifiziert werden konnte ein
ehrt großer planet außerhalb unseres
sonnensystems der an seiner oberfläche
möglicherweise flüssiges wasser wer
backt ist treu 700 de also vielleicht
sogar bewohnbar und handelt es sich bei
diesem exoplaneten sogar um eine zweite
erde und es gibt inzwischen sogar noch
andere exoplaneten mit erdähnlichen
bedingungen und dort könnte es
tatsächlich außerirdisches leben geben
klick zum science fiction gibt es
spannendes seien sie abonniert den kanal
und activity glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen der exoplaneten mit der
bezeichnung 1100d ist gar nicht so weit
von der erde entfernt zumindest in
astronomischen dimensionen gesehen genau
genommen sind es rund 100 lichtjahre die
uns von dem erdboden planeten trend
fachleute wissen bisher das toll 700 der
wohnung etwa 20 prozent größer ist als
die erde und 37 tage braucht um seinen
stern einmal zum kreisen
dieser stern gibt ihm 86 prozent der
energie die unsere erde von der sonne
bekommt doch er ist nicht der einzige
planet der um diesen stern kreist
sondern einer von dreien alle drei
planeten drehen sich nach angaben der
nasa wohl so langsam dass immer deren
selbe seite angestrahlt wird in der
fachsprache ist von einer so genannten
gebundenen rotation die rede
die nasa twittert zu der neuen
entdeckung discovery alert need we knew
the planets discovery beinahe satt essen
bronze planes 1100d ist worldstar
capitals oder liquid quarter koticks ist
unser service 700 bcn die usc die
spektakuläre entdeckung gelang mit dem
nasa-weltraumteleskop kess das ist die
abkürzung für transit in exoplanet
server satellite das wird für die suche
nach exoplaneten eingesetzt die sich in
einer distanz von bis zu 300 lichtjahren
befinden
der start der mission fand im april 2018
mit einer falcon 9 statt der nasa
mitarbeiter paul hertz feiert die
entdeckung als großen erfolg
es wurde speziell entwickelt um
gestartet um er große planeten zu finden
die nahegelegene sterne umkreisen
die entdeckung von 1100 ist eine
wichtige wissenschaftliche erkenntnis
führt es zunächst jedoch hatten die
fachleute in den sternen der von 1100d
umkreis wird falsch eingestuft und das
hatte auch folgen für die drei planeten
die so zunächst irrtümlich für heißer
und größer gehalten wurden als sie
eigentlich sind doch ein schüler und
weitere amateurastronomen und astronomen
deckten den fehler auf das spitzer
weltraumteleskop wurde dann in die
analyse miteinbezogen entlarvte das die
nasa fachleute sich zunächst geirrt
haben dazu emily gilbert von der
university of chicago
als wir die parameter des sterns
korrigierten schrumpften die größe
seiner planeten und wir stellten fest
dass der äußerste von ihnen in etwa die
größe der erde hat und in einer
bewohnbaren zone liegt diese bewohnbare
zone auch habitablen zone genannt ist
für astronomie teams weltweit so etwas
wie der heilige gral der habitablen
zonen handelt es sich um die
umlaufbahnen um sterne auf denen leben
auf planeten prinzipiell möglich wäre
denn in dieser habitablen zone ist es
theoretisch möglich dass wasser fließen
kann und wasser ist die
grundvoraussetzung überhaupt für leben
somit darf ein planet also nicht zu nah
aber auch nicht so weit weg sein von
seinem zentralgestirn denn sowohl dicke
gletscher als auch extreme hitze machen
leben dieser theorie zufolge unmöglich
schon vor rund 40 jahren hatte der us
astronom michael hardt sie begründet und
noch immer ist die theorie der
habitablen zone ein wirklich
aussichtsreiches indiz bei der suche
nach außerirdischem leben zurück
er befindet sich also in der habitablen
zone seines sterns und das macht es
durchaus also möglich dass hier
flüssiges wasser zu finden ist und damit
auch die möglichkeit von außerirdischem
leben doch um eine zweite erde wie es in
vielen schlagzeilen heißt handelt es
sich deswegen noch lange nicht denn ob
es hier tatsächlich wasser gibt ist noch
längst nicht geklärt zudem ist der
exoplaneten nach angaben der nasa
lediglich ehrt groß ob eine
lebensfreundliche atmosphäre existiert
die den planeten zu einer zweiten erde
machen könnte ist bisher unbekannt nasa
forschungsteams nutzen die infos die
bislang über dem planeten bekannt sind
um mit hilfe von computermodellen
vorhersagen zu den genauen bedingungen
auf 1100 den zu treffen eines der
zahlreichen modelle beinhaltet
beispielsweise einen ozean bedeckten
planeten mit einer sehr dichten
atmosphäre in der kohlendioxid dominiert
die beiden anderen planeten
diesem system sind bisherigen
erkenntnissen zufolge sehr
unterschiedlich der innerste planet 1100
b ist so groß und felsig wie unsere erde
und dreht sich alle zehn erdentage um
den stern der zweite stern 1170 c ist
gasförmig und hat wohl eine größe
zwischen die in der erde und die des
neptuns bislang sind uns übrigens etwa
300 exoplaneten bekannt die zu einem
erdgas sind und sich zum anderen in
einer habitablen zone bewegen in der
flüssiges wasser denkbar ist erst vor
kurzem hatten wir hier ja bei klick zum
science und fiction über eine weitere
aufregende entdeckung dass
nasa-satelliten test berichtet der
17-jährige wolf kuka hatte bei seinem
schülerpraktikum bei der nasa einen ganz
besonderen planeten aufgespürt der um
zwei sonnen kreist dazu wolf es ist so
wie luchs heimatplaneten tui in star
wars doch auch für die nasa fachleute
war diese entdeckung eine ganz besondere
überraschung und zudem auch noch eine
premiere denn zuvor hatte testen noch
nie einen planeten in einer umlaufbahn
von zwei sternen aufgespürt in der
fachsprache ist von einem sogenannten
zirka um binären planeten die rede
die genauen analysen ergaben dass der
planet sieben mal so groß ist wie die
erde und etwa 1300 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt liegt konkret befindet er sich
im sternbild viktor neue exoplaneten ist
das die zweite erde auch als low comics
tv hat sich näher mit dieser entdeckung
beschäftigt also anklicken anschauen und
astro comics tv abonnieren mega kanal
bis dann bleib dran